[Music]
so
uh normally when you do tai no hanko
you are subconsciously
picturing the x y axis you're
ignorantly using the 12 6 one
so i'm looking whereas these look your
knees
and then you change direction
in waza though you shouldn't have that
line
you shouldn't have that line in taiwan
but in waza especially when you're doing
kino nagare
the tan khan goes
not where an arbitrary geometry set
where i can stay in this back corner
behind him
so if you look at the 12 6
line this line
you'll see that i actually am not doing
a 12 6
10 10
so i can stay behind him
[Music]
he tells me where i think
equally 12-6
he goes around and i do this
i'm still in front of him
here i'm in front of him
i have to stay in that back corner
so as we're moving around boom i'm back
here
again i'll step where he tells me to
step
and when he tells me to step not
wherever
stay in the back in other words
popcorn
[Music]
here is always going to be slow
if it is not your gaming
that gets your hand out of the grip
because you will have to do two moves as
one after the other so you're gonna go
here
we'll leave it at this angle and you're
gonna have to go
wait one two
let us assume that you're actually
strong enough
to do that i know i'm not
i'm not going to do that at any kind of
marshally viable
speed it's not aikido either
so this grip release is using the same
principle you
use all the time overstress the tendons
in the forearm so the fingers start to
malfunction
the grip now loses its integrity and you
can get out
so how i do that is with
leave that there and enter and you'll be
out so he's here
boom the grips already weaken
by going for the elbow not by pulling
this
off leaving it in its weakened state
enter and his wrist will have will try
to follow
and as it does it's going to move into
that position
and you are escaped
your body does the escape
so
so you'll know you're doing it
incorrectly
if there is a moment when his hand's not
on my wrist
and i'm not touching his elbow
if you did it correctly
you will be on his elbow at the time it
comes off
your arm not before a womb
because that's the movement that gets my
wrist out
this is dreaming okay and so
as you're trying to move you have all
you can't keep the because you have to
wait
you have to wait for there you go
just keep going
okay let's go you cannot just step
wherever on the elimi for the
um so uh
when i go out i can't i can't step here
i can't step there i can't step too deep
i can't step too shallow
there is a particular place i have to be
and you're not going to have a new
uh tactic
aikido uses the same tactics
all the time so there's not a new
introduction of a tencon
or an elimi angle is the same
so if i was to do a mote
let's say let's just get to the elimi
same thing i can't go into the armpit it
doesn't matter even if i bring my arm
here you can see it starts to rotate him
and i can't go obviously behind
there's a place i have to go and that
place
is always referencing his four corners
the four corners that i use i also use
against him
so this will make more sense if he's in
uh
some kind of guard defense and let's
just look at a
knee pass so whatever knee pass you're
doing
this knee of mine always goes
into this hip area right here
if i go down low he'll bring he'll be
able to bring his knee up and i'm back
where i was
even if i'm threading down here as i
come around
i'll get half guard or he'll be able to
thread it
again and i'm back in
so where when i thread the knee
the knee slice i'm always interested in
that pocket
right there another way of looking at it
is side control how does that mean
here if i want to
pressure my cross face on him and i
i want to lean let's say i do this leg
but let's say for some reason i do this
leg
i've now freed that hip and he's going
to get
me back in which is why if i'm going to
move this knee from that hip
i have to first replace it and now he
can't do that maneuver
this hip corner
is vital because it checks his leg
weapons out
the ability for him to use his lower
extremities
so uh let's say he's going
boom and he comes let's say he comes
forward all right i'm going to be able
to rotate
behind him
he was too far forward of the hip corner
now he's going to go back too far back
you see and just like
when i remove my knee from the side
control
he does not control my knee boom
what you want to see is the line of
attack potential there
so when i come in just like on a mote
i'm coming in in front of that hip
and like all aikido that angle of
cancellation on the leg
is concentric with the kazushi angle
it's concentric with the front inward
spiral
so as his head goes that way his hip
goes that way
so i use the arm of ikkyo to bring his
head that way
and the edemi takes his hip down
so i'm always going to use that tactic
but i do achieve it slightly differently
in ura than in omote
so i come around
you're going to see this change angle
that as i enter in front of that hip i
can't be
as close as i was in a mote
i'm back here and when i begin the
rotation
rather than in a mote i bring my hip to
him
in this ura i bring his hip to me
so i don't want to go here yes you did
it
but this is not weak for turning i go in
here
and in the rotation i bring this hip to
me
but the angle on that is in front of
that
here
not way back here
and not way in here
you use that hip as a reference point
boom
pop here a head on the spiral there
because concentrically when i am
too far forward this is
to my right and it's going to be hard to
get to my left
and weirdly when i'm too far back
same thing these moves here
are not going to work
i step where i need to be
and his elbow will be on my center line
the entire time
boom
[Music]
so again just micro drilling that
here ahead and elbow hands
on my center line and drill
boom hip boom
elbow hand goes to my center
[Music]
every one of these is a failure
don't kid yourself even if your uk goes
for you
let's go how do i achieve the throw
let's go to here oh i'm doing the inward
spiral
[Music]
and that spiral gets the
front inward position
this
but is want to make sure that you're
doing that
boom right here boom
otherwise you have a person that's just
standing there and you're
dreaming again
let's say for example he feels his
balance and he lets go
well you don't grab that arm
i think you're going to do ikea
he's going to be too much bass okay
so let's just say that happens i come
around here let's go
i have to go to this
[Music]
but i must treat a standing person
as a person that is fully capable of
fighting
can't be someone i just can take his arm
and move him around
so make sure that you have a good
positioning angle
that you establish the front inward
slough
boom okay because
that throws his weight on the other leg
and what's going to happen it's one of
two things as i come into
this
he will either
and what everyone should do is he will
bring that foot around
and that usually f's everyone up except
for the choreography you get who only
does that to step down
and lower themselves but
if i'm doing my
adhesion to do what you're seeing
as bringing him around as opposed to my
leverage
is this is sliding them around
not fulcrum lever fulcrum lever
and centrifugal energy i'm not doing
that
that's not keto nagar then boom
he goes into that spiral and is bringing
him around this way
he then does that step and i'll
go back to this drill
the ikea adhesion loads up the coq
projection so
he has energy he's got to give me energy
for this to work
so i yield and boom he hits
the cochlea
as he steps he presses into the elbow
hand
which moves from the eye kid adhesion to
the cookie projection
then i just stay up with him so he threw
himself
and i stand with him
[Music]
it looks like me going down is what
shoves him down
it is not i'm just staying with him
so you actually need his countering
resistance
his non-surrendering
okay so going back to this
and the uh the uke who's not alive
okay so remember how you were bending
he's basically countering the cochlea
projection
so if he's got energy in his arm then
you can protect him but
as he goes mushy
your energy gets like steam out of a
leaky valve but
what you what you do is you find his
uh projection so even even though i
touch his uh chest i'm not pushing
so let's try to let me not make it so
confusing
okay so he's gonna he's trying he's
letting his arm bend this way
do you see that yes so i can find it
around
going around that point and find his
center back inside his hand
so here we're doing the technique
and you'll see he's not
taking that counterstep
and i said that's one of the two things
that shirouki will do
it does not mean that as you come around
you're now doing a standard
disequilibrium
it falls outside his base of support and
i
keep pushing it now
you're still doing a pokey projection
you're just doing it on that foot
there we go that foot i still project
so here's me pushing it down
and here's me projecting it down
the feeling should still be the same
oh you should protect to project on
whatever
um young energy he's giving you
he's always going to give you young
energy even if he takes it out of the
arm
you will always find it because his
matter and his gravity is always going
to give you some yawn so don't start
pushing this
find the projection find the center
so you can do a projection and then you
stay up with the projection
boom violence boom
i stand for the projection it's not me
using my weight and overpowering him
he pushes into me i reconcile the young
energy
and then i return it
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
cheers